it's funny I got a bunch of they asked
me for a couple of pictures for the
Patrice documentary that they're just
they asked me for a couple of old photos
so that way you were yeah yeah yeah I
went to like this shoebox of old photos
and I post it I didn't post any Patrice
with the shoebox it in the mementos box
it was right next to it oh and there's a
couple in there I forgot about there's a
couple of Brazil pictures and I posted
three of myself like for all you know
from like 94 my first headshot which is
awful my pit stains that shot it wasn't
meant to be was just a picture at ARMA
John somebody took and I want to be
using it as my first headshot
I love the angle yeah it's a weird angle
to it cuz it's pointing down on you feet
look like they're two inches they do
yeah yeah your little little size for
lady feet you're wearing big giant like
Zubaz style pants yeah and you have tiny
little feet under it taking the shirt in
yeah you got your your mock turtleneck
tucked in yeah and you're flexing but
you do you can eat your pit stains are
so bad it's a black shirt and you could
still clip the pit stains are still the
first thing you still see them locked in
yeah it's not a good look that was my
thinking look cool better than your
driver's license that was my first why'd
those pant legs the first few years of
performing it's very MC Hammer it was
yeah that was popular back then though
that's like an album or a book cover
yeah photo you think so yeah do you
think it's a good picture it's a great
thing good for me yeah
not good for you no because it pit
stains were never in style no they
really weren't even in the even in the
early 90s people weren't like oh man I
gotta get pit stains on my shirt yeah
that became my first headshot they used
it they shouldn't have when I was
started getting a little paid gigs so
yeah who's that and what made you want
to like flex your muscles it was just a
joker so it wasn't a real flex it was
just a silly because some I was onstage
is suppose taking a picture so I
probably did that that was the open mic
you'd stayed on that parquet floor and
that was where I did a lot of that's
where I met an Aries Spears I believe
that's the gig I met Aries at like in
1991 or whatever Wow when his mom would
take him cuz he was yeah he's couple
years younger than me and his mom would
support him it was really even back then
you knew that that was not common for a
guy that young to be that
funny so how old are you there I'm 22
man maybe 21 23 match I mean I think 21
22
well you're sweating like a 30 year old
I was sweating like a nervous 21 year
old look like Karen Feehan you had a
license photo latitude I mean you're
such it you were such a tough day I was
but he was cute I was a rough-and-tumble
boy yeah you look quite cute in that
photo he's like a baby face from the
wrong side of the tracks
I forget like you forget what you're a
grown up how young you looked at the
time like oh yeah always think is you
always see yourself as the same god damn
I was [ __ ] baby he looks like you
hung out with Ponyboy get burned
oh that's what stuck 94 yeah yeah he's
26 years ago like when you think of
Woodstock 94 you probably just think of
it like you doing it right you don't
realize that you're gonna look at that
photo and you're like that looks like a
different person you're not getting
right and there's a bunch more photos
like I scanned them with that thing that
you showed me but it's harder to
transfer them as footnote on your in
your notes at mmm PDFs though I didn't
take pictures I could have taken
pictures of the pictures but for some
reason scanning just grabbed it and did
it ease I don't know what's better
quality I'm not sure that's cool that
you did Woodstock 94 though I found my
first itinerary with dice that Kenny
sent me from like May of 1998 that's
whenever I started with dice
like mr. Norton a little no dear oh I
said everything man I'm so happy I have
that sure love you go through your
mementos box last night just listening
to Lake music from The Wonder Years yeah
looking back on everything unless you
and what's-his-name Marv from home alone
just narrating the voice-over as you
think about your days as a boy
you